I received a really interesting email
from Russell this week who said it would
be interesting to discuss that Donald
Trump appears to be the first truly
atheist president of the United States
but for whatever reason it's not really
being discussed and maybe just as
importantly the evangelical right-wing
Christians still voted for Donald Trump
over Hillary Clinton and this is a
really interesting topic cuz there's a
few different angles to it
first of all Trump does appear to be at
minimum completely non-religious in the
sort of dogmatic belief sense if not an
out-and-out atheist but it's just not
been part of the narrative around Donald
Trump and I would argue that the reason
it's not been part of the narrative is
because it's wholly irrelevant to Donald
Trump's governance and also because
Donald Trump took the correct position
on abortion for those who vote based on
religion that is all that matters
Trump's personal religiosity much like
Trump's personal history with women much
like Trump's personal history with all
sorts of other stuff that you wouldn't
think would appeal to the evangelical
vote does not matter as long as Donald
Trump takes what they believe to be the
correct position on the issue of
abortion so let's first go through the
case for believing that Donald Trump is
an atheist or agnostic or non-religious
number one there's really been no
mention of Donald Trump's holiday plans
when it comes to church services around
Christmas or whatever other holiday
there's no mentions of Donald Trump's
use of the White House Chapel or the
Camp David Chapel I mean we just never
hear about any of it whatsoever number
two there have been no references to
Trump's church membership in New York
City throughout his entire life other
than I believe it was in South Carolina
during the campaign Trump said that he's
a Presbyterian Protestant and that he
goes to marble Collegiate Church as
often as he can which seemed like a lie
especially since marble Collegiate
Church in Manhattan is reformed not
Presbyterian and most people who go to a
church regularly and our religious know
what the religious denomination is of
the church that they're going to it'd be
sort of weird not to know your own
religion that's strange the church also
said that Donald Trump is not an
if member of that shirt so that just
seemed like a pandering lie George W
Bush George HW Bush's funeral you might
recall that Donald Trump clearly didn't
know the religious songs and the prayers
or whatever it was that was being sung
he the other presidents and their
significant others were singing those
songs confidently and Donald Trump had
no clue what was going on now that could
be just Trump's general ignorance it
could be his lack of reading ability
which we've talked about but
coincidentally it's religious stuff that
Donald Trump seems to be clueless about
when he was asked about Bible verses he
claimed that the Bible was one of his
favorite books along with the art of the
deal but when he was asked again well
what's one of your favorite verses he
says I wouldn't want to get into it
because it's very personal and I don't
really want to get into specific Bible
verses but then in a different moment he
had his infamous 2 Corinthians moments
that made absolutely no sense and people
who know about Corinthians said 2
Corinthians is not the way anybody who
is actually familiar with religious
texts would cite it so it's actually
unclear only because of Trump's
ignorance right on the one hand Trump
might just be ignorant about religion in
the same sense that he's ignorant about
so many other things without actually
being an atheist or a non-believer on
the other hand if this or any other
person who exhibited the characteristics
I've just told you we would say oh yeah
that's absolutely an atheist now
interestingly even if Trump is an
atheist it doesn't really seem that he
would be the first atheist president
there are a number of presidents that
are believed to have been atheists even
if they didn't say it publicly in those
words which in at times passed in the
United States would have been
particularly problematic so you have
Thomas Jefferson Jefferson was accused
of being an atheist as a campaign
strategy by his opponents but it's
likely that he was a deist and a free
thinker so not an atheist per se but
very non religious relative to the sort
of cultural and religious climate of the
time Abraham Lincoln people around
Lincoln including William Herndon said
that Lincoln's religious views were
complicated and that at times he was an
atheist
and that Lincoln was really a follower
of Darwin not of religion although
publicly Lincoln still did pay lip
service to being a religious person you
have ulysses s grant not affiliated with
any church considered to be a Methodist
but never baptized went to church rarely
reportedly only did it to appease his
wife who was religious and in his death
note to his wife he mentioned meeting
her in another world which suggests at
least some belief in an afterlife but
significant speculation that he was not
a religious man and then you have
William Howard Taft William Howard Taft
was described as a Unitarian often sort
of like what we would call non-religious
Christianity or hipster Christianity or
less religious Christianity Christian
atheism so to speak
once Taft said I believe in God I do not
believe in the divinity of Christ so
sort of judge it for the times and
evaluate as you will but the bottom line
here is number one most importantly
Donald Trump is still a terrible
president whether he's religious or not
number two Donald Trump still panders to
religious groups recognizing that they
are a predominantly important
significantly important voting bloc if
you were running as a Republican he
still has opening prayers at events he
participated in the anti-abortion march
march for life I believe it's called
claiming I don't know if we believe it
but he claims to have had an awakening
relatively late in his life well into
adulthood about a kid that was born
after the mother thought about having an
abortion but didn't and that that
changed him from being a lifelong
pro-choice individual to being
anti-abortion coincidentally very
shortly before deciding to run for
president so this is why it's
functionally irrelevant whether Trump's
deeply held beliefs are religious or not
this is similar to what I said earlier
in the week people say well we don't
know if deep down Trump is a racist we
don't know if deep down Trump is
xenophobic his public presence as Prez
of the united states as
commander-in-chief of the united states
is a presence that is both racist and
xenophobic he is functionally racist and
xenophobic he is coalescing racists and
xenophobes around his nationalist
ideology and his campaign ideas and all
of the rhetoric that he's espousing so
does it matter deep down whether Trump
is actually racist in his heart of
hearts in his mind of minds no it
doesn't matter and similarly I would
make the case that yeah I do believe
that Donald Trump partially just out of
complete and total ignorance of religion
and partially because religion has never
been important to him is probably a
non-believer he is probably at minimum
and agnostic if I had to guess deep down
but it doesn't really matter because
publicly he is functionally pandering to
the religious right in basically the
same way that most Republican candidates
and presidents and elected officials in
the House and Senate have done and it
makes the question of his deep down
sincerely held religious beliefs
practically irrelevant from the point of
view of governance and from the point of
view of what it is that he is going to
signify to evangelicals when he says I'm
against abortion despite the fact that
he's had the sexual assault allegations
and alleged rape of his ex-wife and the
affairs and the videos with Jeffrey
Epstein touching women on the rear end
does not clear that that's what they
want it doesn't really matter because
he's functionally taken the correct
position on the most important religious
voting issue and that is the issue of
abortion if you disagree with me that
Trump is likely not religious let me
know I'm on Twitter at de Pakman if you
disagree with me that his sincerely held
beliefs actually do matter as much as or
more than the public representation on
issues of importance to religion then
let me know basically if you disagree
with anything in my analysis I'd like to
hear from you I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show we're going to open the phone lines
shortly we are going to answer audience
questions and a lot of very relevant and
important topics to be discussed on
today's show
if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video